[Musique]
c'est gentil de me recevoir j'ai deux
mauvais pressentiment par exemple j'ai
eu peur bleue de me faire écraser
projeté pas négatif c'est sûr je suis
déjà trompé vous êtes une charnel à
canal parle ou kenzo s'exprime avec
quelqu'un du monde des esprits
oui il s'appelle comment cet informateur
je n'ai pas leur a dévoilé son identité
vous avez déjà permis d'éviter 14 attend
confirmation cible 13 vous désirez
j'entends une voix une seule toujours là
même qui me dit tout ce qui se passe
autour de moi j'ai perdu albert fert du
vert qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi tu me parles genre quoi un
vieux avec une voix douce et un accent
moi ça la péruvienne un falafel de ja
cattori ça marche comment ils advini à
midi j'ai pris votre commande mais je
n'ai pas pris que commandes seront pas
que c'était contagieux la voyant son
c'est une entité qui m'a quittée pour
voler chez vous à moi dans ma tête c'est
qui ces d'esprit la mort c'est un esprit
d'un niveau très supérieur à l'est père
albert l'entraîneur du psg pour son
estomac
ça va à l'estomac c'est psychosomatique
c'est le coeur qui va ou la lch et cet
hiver pas organismes on filtre pour un
voyant il faut regarder devant lui
vous êtes complètement match
comment vous sentez-vous recyclables je
vous envie ce mec de ma tête
c'est un type qui s'appelle albert et
qui est rentré en moi et vous étiez
consentants absolument pas
[Musique]